The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to 6.890.
Today, we will do many more
hardness proofs, mostly
of games and puzzles and some
graph theoretic problems, all
reducing from 3SAT.
We're going to continue where
we left off last time, which
was with this picture,
which also comes
from lecture 1, which is how to
prove Super Mario Brothers is
NP-hard.
We had two main gadgets,
the variable gadget,
which forces your player to
choose going left or right,
and the clause
gadget, which could
be visited in three different
ways in order to enable it.
These each contained
an invincibility star,
so that if later, you come
through to traverse the gadget,
you can get through all
these fire bars if and only
if there was at
least one star there.
So that was a
regular 3SAT clause.
And then, there's the
connectivity in between.
And so in particular, you
need a crossover gadget
with this set-up.
But the general idea
is you visit variable,
visit all the clauses
that are in it
that include that literal-- you
get to choose only one-- then
you go to the next
variable, next variable.
And then, you traverse
all the clauses
and you can get to
finish if and only
if the 3SAT formula
was satisfiable.
This is a general
construction or approach
for platform video games.
That's what we were presenting
it as in a recent paper.
I thought I'd show you a few
other Nintendo games you can
prove hard with this technique.
This is the clause gadget
for Super Mario World.
So in Super Mario
World, there are
these great question-mark blocks
and in particular, POW blocks,
which go back to the
original Mario Brothers
without the "Super."
How many people
played Mario Brothers?
Really old-school,
pre-Super Mario.
And anyway, it doesn't matter
exactly where it comes from.
It does something completely
different in Super Mario World,
which is turns all
coins into things
you can walk on for 10 seconds.
But you can't normally
hit a question-mark block
except from the bottom.
There's no way to do that here.
But if you can visit one
of these three places,
you can send one of these
turtle shells flying
and it will hit this and bring
the POW block off and then
disappear, so that later when
you try to traverse this clause
gadget, if there's a POW
block, you can turn these
into solid things for
long enough to get across
but no longer than that.
So in the next gadget, you need
another POW block, and so on.
So that's clause gadget
for Super Mario World.
The other gadgets
are pretty similar,
so I'll just show you that one.
AUDIENCE: Does the
star trick not work?
PROFESSOR: I guess you could
also do the star trick,
but I think we drew this figure
before we did the star trick.
So we thought, oh,
this is cooler.
Now, one thing I thought
I'd mention briefly
is some fun glitches you can
do in the real Super Mario
Brothers, as
implemented on the ROMs.
You can do these crazy things
like jump off of walls.
You're not supposed
to be able to do this
and this level would be
unsolvable in the way you would
normally think about
Super Mario Brothers,
but there happens to be this
fun subpixel resolution.
I think this is
usually very hard to do
with a real controller,
but much easier
to do when you can slow things
down 100 times and every frame,
you have a choice of whether
to push a particular button.
That's called tool-assisted
speed runs, usually.
I don't know if you consider
this real Super Mario
Brothers or not.
It depends on your
notion of reality,
whether you're more of a
mathematician or a gamer,
I guess.
But you can try to modify
the gadget so that wall
jumping doesn't help you.
So you could imagine trying
to jump up these walls.
But if there's things in
the way, it prevents it.
So if you just add that
to every vertical tunnel,
that will prevent going
back up the tunnels, which
is important for the
variable gadgets.
We don't want to be able
to reverse our decision
and later choose the
opposite variable setting.
Here's another fun set of cheats
where you jump through walls.
This one is apparently somewhat
doable on a real controller,
but still quite challenging.
I think that one of
the general ideas
is the collision detection
is not super good in the game
as implemented.
So if you get just
the right geometry,
you can walk through the walls.
There's instructions for you.
So this is obviously problematic
because all of our gadgets
involve walls.
So if you can walk through
them, not very interesting.
So a general approach is to
just add lots of monsters
into the walls.
So even if you could walk
through, you become small Mario
and then that's not an option.
I should say these have
not been thoroughly tested,
so it's plausible you can walk
through the wall in such a way
that maybe you kill the monster
or there may be other glitches
that we don't know about.
And so you might consider
this a work in progress.
But generally, I would believe
you can modify the proof
to work on real Super Mario
Brothers as implemented
in real physics, of course,
generalized to an n by n screen
and so on.
What exactly you call
"real" is challenging there.
But that's Super Mario
Brothers-- just some more fun
stuff in the paper.
Let me talk a little bit
about Legend of Zelda.
This is what it looks like,
in case you've never seen it.
And this is the original
Legend of Zelda.
You're a little character.
You can walk around.
And this is what I would say is
a typical block-pushing puzzle
in Legend of Zelda, which
is try all the blocks
and hope that one
of then pushes.
And I have to say, I
watched an entire-- I
don't know how long it was--
five hours of walkthrough
of Legend of Zelda
wanting to find
whether there are
any more complicated
block-pushing puzzles.
I swear I remember a slightly
more complicated one,
but I could not find it.
It's possible it skipped in
this particular walkthrough.
Well, it just takes a long time.
But you get it.
All right, we're almost done.
You get an idea of
what the game is like.
You've got a sword, whatever.
That won't be particularly
relevant to our reductions.
There will be no monsters
in our reductions.
In this case, I think you just
have to wait a really long time
or possibly kill the
hand that comes out.
Then, you can push that block.
He actually tried to
push it in the beginning,
but it wouldn't move.
Anyway, that's Legend of Zelda.
Here's a slightly
more interesting one.
This is what I remember.
Normally, you push one,
two, three, and then
you push this to the side.
In this particular case, blocks
are not pushable sideways,
which is really annoying.
So you actually have to
solve it a different way.
If you watch this video, at this
point, he's like, oh, my god.
This was the simplest
block-pushing puzzle ever
and I solved it.
Yea!
It's after half an hour
of trying other things.
That's the joy of Legend
of Zelda, very fun puzzles,
so to speak.
So the point is, you have
block-pushing puzzles.
We already know-- oh, sorry.
Here's one more, I guess.
These are in Legend of
Zelda-- A Link to the Past.
So it has a slightly
more com-- there's
an actual slightly nontrivial
block-pushing puzzle.
But in general, we
know push-one is hard.
Most versions of Legend of Zelda
are slightly more restrictive
than push-one.
I would call them
"push-once" blocks,
where you can only
push one at a time.
That's your strength.
But also, you can only
push a block once.
You can never push
it a second time
or push it back or do
anything like that.
And with some slight-- this
is the gadget we saw before.
With some slight tweaks,
you can make the locks still
work when you're only allowed
to push each block once.
So that proves that most
versions of Legend of Zelda
are at least NP-hard, because
they include block pushing.
But it would be
nice to understand
other senses in which
these kinds of games
are hard without
using block pushing.
So here's another feature
called the hookshot.
So you select it
and then if there's
an object on the other side,
you can hookshot to that side.
So you can't walk
over the cavern,
but you can hookshot across.
Here it is again.
As long as there's an
object over there--
you can also pick up
objects and destroy them.
So does that make it hard
with no pushing blocks?
Well, a little bit
of pushing blocks.
Here's a simple proof
using that structure.
So here's a variable.
I go from top to bottom.
You see over here a
treasure chest or something
that you can hookshot onto
to go over the cavern.
And here, you have a choice.
You can go left or
you can go right,
but then you can't back up,
because there's no object
here to hookshot onto.
You can only do it orthogonally.
Here's a clause.
If you come down any
one of these paths,
then you can push
this block one step.
And then, you'll be able
to hookshot from the right
to get onto this platform and
then continue to the left.
And a crossover is really
easy in this world.
So you could come up with
lots of different NP-hardness
proofs.
So this is a fun one
for A Link to the Past,
which is the first game
that has that hookshot.
This is Metroid.
If you've never played,
most of the time
you spend going up and
down elevator shafts.
And there are these monsters
which you can shoot.
And then, there's
also this ability
to become a one-by-one block
instead of a two-by-one block
and roll through small things.
When you're in that position,
in a certain part of the game,
you are not allowed to shoot.
So that's the situation
we're going to imagine.
So here is a clause
in a crossover.
The variable gadget
is the same as Mario.
You fall left or fall right.
You can't go back up, because
you have a limited jump height.
So let's do the clause first.
There are three different
ways to visit it.
When you're setting your
variables, if you can get here,
you can aim upwards and just
shoot all of these things.
It would take a few
minutes, but you'd
get rid of all these guys.
These guys just walk
around constantly.
And then, to
traverse, you're going
to be coming through
here in ball mode.
There's no way
to-- I guess, here,
you could briefly stand up,
but you can't shoot down
in original Metroid.
So you want to roll
over here, but you
would take too much damage.
You maybe only have
one hit point left,
so if there's any
of these guys left,
you have to visit at
least one of these
to kill all the monsters
and then get through.
That's clause.
Crossover is a little
more challenging.
In this case, we set things up--
the idea is you come in here
and you want to leave out there.
So it's uni-directional.
You can't go up in this gadget.
And the idea is
there's a little gap
and it's moving this way as
the monsters move around.
So you wait for the
gap to come here.
Then, you go down
and then, you're
basically forced in timing
when you fall down this cavern.
And it's set up so that by the
time this thing gets to here,
these guys will have
come to the other side.
Then, you have to
roll to the right
in order to avoid taking
damage from these guys who
are going around the
other way and similarly
in the other direction.
So you have to get the timing
right and we haven't exactly
tested this yet, but it should
be approximately correct.
And that will force a crossover.
Should be a simpler way, but
that's the best crossover
we have currently.
So Metroid is NP.
Here, we actually
claim NP-completeness,
because there isn't too
much state to the game.
So the issue here is the
length of a solution polynomial
length.
If it is, then it's
in NP and NP-complete.
And here, you can kill
each monster only once.
So that's the idea for--
and the amount of state
you have is just your position
and what items you currently
have.
So you should be able
to solve this in NP
and that sort of
settles the complexity.
Most of these other problems
could potentially be harder
than NP and we have
some other results
like that, which
we may get to when
we're talking about PSPACE.
But today is about NP.
Here's Donkey Kong Country.
If you haven't played,
this is a speed run
and you can kill
monsters by rolling.
Most of the time, you're
jumping and collecting bananas.
There are these bees
that if you touch them,
you die or you sort of
have two hit points.
And then, there
are these barrels
you can pick up-- that's a
giant bee-- you can pick up
certain barrels and then
throw them at a monster
and, in this case,
damage, usually kill them.
Then, there are
these other types
of barrels that
when you touch them,
they shoot you in a
predefined direction
and let you collect
lots of bananas.
So those are the rules of
Donkey Kong in a nutshell,
in a banana shell.
AUDIENCE: In a banana peel?
PROFESSOR: Sorry, in a
banana peel, thank you.
So here's a simple
crossover with that setup.
You just have these
barrels that shoot you
in a predefined
direction and force
you to go through
this intersection
without any choice.
When you're being
shot, you cannot move.
So that's easy.
Again, variables
the same as Mario,
you fall left or fall right.
And a clause-- it's a little
hard to see with the background
here, but there's a
little ledge here.
And you can come down this
way, pick up this barrel,
and throw it over here.
And it will eventually
hit this bee,
so that later, you can
traverse this gadget
without dying from the bee.
So not drawn is a platform
that you need to-- or maybe
you're falling all the
way through these things
if you set up all the
clauses vertically.
And if there's any bee left,
you will die, otherwise not,
and so you have to
visit at least one
of these three barrels
to kill the bee.
And I think this is a
mechanism to prevent you
from carrying this barrel
anywhere else, like climbing up
or something.
Anyway, that's
Donkey Kong Country.
I think there's
one more, Pokemon.
I'm kind of embarrassed.
I've never actually
played a Pokemon game.
I don't know if I
should admit this,
but I need to sit down and
play them all some weekend.
I did watch Twitch
play it for a while.
AUDIENCE: Going back
to the previous slide,
in some of the other gadgets,
if we satisfied a clause,
there was no way to--
there was a barrier
between setting the
clause and going
through the rest of that thing.
So potentially, you could
get to the last clause
here, kill the bee, and just
walk forward without-- can
we with the rest of the stuff?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
Yeah, I think
probably the right way
to set this up-- I'm not quite
sure how to do it directly
from the drawing, but an easy
way to do it would be there's
no floor below here.
And at the end, when you
solved all the things,
there is one of
these barrels that
shoots you straight to the left
until you get to the finish.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
PROFESSOR: So if you tried
to exit the clause early,
you would just
fall to your death,
because there's only one barrel
shooting way over on the right.
That would be one solution.
I forget exactly
what's in the paper,
but it wouldn't surprise
me if it's that.
Yeah, good question.
You definitely don't want
to be able to just visit
the last clause, kill
the guy, and then exit.
That would be cheating.
But in these proofs,
that's always
what you have to worry about
is this type of cheating.
Other questions?
Cool.
Pokemon time-- so Pokemon is
a somewhat complicated game.
It's a lot of different
abilities and so on.
So we had to abstract things
away and in these pictures,
there are two types
of-- I haven't
defined any of the rules yet.
You are a little person
walking around here.
You're carrying
Pokemon, whatever.
And there are these
characters called
trainers and the red trainers
are called "weak" trainers.
These are people
that when you visit,
they just sort of deactivate.
You beat them.
And then, there's blue trainers.
We'll call them
"strong" trainers.
Those are ones that no
matter when or how you try
to play them, you always die.
And so you fail, so you never
want to visit a blue trainer.
Now, trainers have two
kinds of-- let's talk
about variables maybe.
This is an easy situation.
So a variable, you want
to come in the "in"
and either leave in the
"false" or leave in the "true."
And there are two ways
to activate a trainer.
One is to walk into their
field of view, which are
drawn with these rectangles.
If you walk to this position,
the trainer will walk to you
and then you fight the trainer.
And because it's
red, you'll win.
And so in that case,
the trainers moved here.
Trainers are obstacles, so you
can't get to the true anymore.
You have to go around to false.
The other way you
can visit a trainer
is to talk to them from
the side or from behind.
So you can walk here, talk
to the trainer, beat them,
then they deactivate.
Then, you can walk this way.
And you can only
fight them once.
Then, it's over.
They won't move anymore.
So that forces you
to do true or false
and then commit
to that decision.
And these are obviously
obstacles that are immovable.
All right.
So the idea with the
clause is the following.
When you're traversing
the clause at the end,
you want to walk
through here and leave.
And the worry is this position.
If this trainer can come
to you, you will die.
So that will be possible
exactly when all of these guys
are out of the way.
When will they come
out of the way?
When you walk through
them-- and none of them
have been activated yet.
So then, they will
walk one space to you.
You'll win, but it's temporary.
You win the battle, lose the
war, because when you get here,
then this guy can walk through.
But these serve as
obstacles otherwise.
So if you can come
down one of these paths
and visit the trainer
early, then later when
you come through, they
will not move toward you.
They will stay an obstacle for
this guy in, so this guy cannot
walk to you.
This is just to make a barrier.
And then, you can get through.
Crossover, you get
the idea, right?
We could try to walk through
it, but it's definitely
complicated.
In general, we want to go from
x to x prime or y to y prime.
Again, it's directional.
And now that I know the
right color assignment--
red is weak-- I would guess
this guy is an obstacle.
But as soon as you go this way,
this guy moves out of the way.
So it kind of closes off
trying to return this way.
So once you come
through here, this
would be a problem to come back.
So that kind of cuts
you off from going back
and it's kind of
like the crossover
we saw with push-one
2D, I believe.
Then, you probably go here.
A similar thing happens.
This guy will approach, come to
you, and then you can escape.
When you get here, this guy
will come all the way down.
Oh, that looks bad.
AUDIENCE: Can you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
probably we should
have talked to him early.
So then, we can come through
here without any trouble,
succeed in getting
down to y prime.
You have to check that
you can't get to x prime.
This looks like an impossible
nexus to get through,
but these guys can walk through.
That's the reason
they're there instead
of just being obstacles.
Left to right should be-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: They can only see
you five or six tiles away.
PROFESSOR: This is a
generalized Pokemon.
Yeah, it would be nice.
Obviously, this is a
bounded visibility.
It would be nice to
get that down smaller,
but at least this shows
constant visibility is enough,
because these gadgets
are all local.
It would maybe also be nice.
Are they all the
same visibility?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's just
some fixed amount of tiles.
PROFESSOR: So it would be nice
if they were also all the same.
That does not currently hold,
but it wouldn't surprise me
if that-- well, yeah, tricky.
All right.
I'll just mention for a
little bit of Pokemon cred,
this is one paragraph
of our paper
where we construct the weak
and the strong trainers
using exactly the setup that's
available in various Pokemon
games.
I believe in every
single game there
are enough abilities that you
can set up so that you either
force the bad guy to all
he can do is self-destruct
or all he can do is kill you and
you lose, that sort of thing.
But it requires some
Pokemon expertise which
Alan Guo had in this case.
He's a PhD student
in C-Cell here.
Any other questions
about Nintendo games
before we move on?
AUDIENCE: This is a common
sort of Pokemon specific.
In Generation One, moves
can miss with a one and two
[INAUDIBLE] even if
their accuracy is 100%.
Are you good with this?
AUDIENCE: It's self-destructing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: The self-destruct
means he doesn't die.
AUDIENCE: No, the
self-destruct doesn't matter
whether he does damage, right?
It's just
self-destruct, you die.
AUDIENCE: I think self-destruct,
the death doesn't actually
happen if the attack misses.
Can you?
PROFESSOR: No, it does.
It does.
AUDIENCE: Really?
OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it does.
We'll have to go play.
All right.
The next game I'm
going to talk about
is a sort of physical game
that you play on usually a go
board with go stones.
So they're white stones
and black stones.
It was invented by
this guy, John Conway.
And so if you've ever played
Conway's Game of Life,
that's a zero-player game.
This is an actual two-player
game and quite challenging.
Here's the general idea.
There's a right player trying
to get the white ball-- that's
the "football."
This is philosophers'
football, if you will.
You're trying to get this
ball over to that goal
and the left player's trying to
get the ball to the right goal.
Then, there are these black
pieces, which are called "men."
Those are the players of
the game, so to speak.
And there are two types
of moves in this game.
One move you can do is just
place a black stone anywhere
on the board that's
currently empty.
And the other type of move
is the more complicated one.
This is called
"kicking the ball."
You can take the
white piece and you
can jump it over a string
of consecutive black pieces.
Those pieces are
immediately removed,
so this gray shading
means they've
been removed from the board.
But in the same move, you
can do several such jumps.
So I can jump here.
Then, I can jump here.
And everything I jump
over-- in this case, I won.
If I'm the right player,
I got to that position.
So this is why
the right player--
from the original
position, maybe they
wanted to place this stone
because that would enable
in their next move-- you
can't place a black stone
and then jump.
You can do one or the other.
So you could try to
place this position,
place this stone hoping
that in your next turn,
you'll be able to do
this jump and win.
But instead from this position,
the left player could say,
oh, well, I'll just add this
stone and then in my next move,
I'll be able to jump
to the right side.
And that's, I
think, unblockable.
So left wins.
Yea!
So that's the setup.
This is a fairly
complicated game.
You can get to the same
position multiple times
and so it's actually open
how hard this game is.
I think there's an
upper bound of it
being solvable in exponential
time, so it's in EXP.
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by "solvable?"
PROFESSOR: So given
a position, you
want to know whether
left or right will
win from this position.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible
that it doesn't terminate?
PROFESSOR: I could be a
tie is the right answer.
So that's tricky.
There is a piece-base hardness
result relatively recent,
but an old result of
ours with David Eppstein
is that just determining
whether you can win in one move
is NP-complete.
So that's a relatively
clean thing.
You don't have to worry
about non-termination
or that sort of thing.
It's just one player's move.
Here, everything is reversed.
The ball is black in this case.
I'm not sure if there's a
consistent notion, anyway.
And this is actually a
reduction all on one slide.
It's pretty simple.
So this is what we call
the mate in one problem.
And you can take lots
of different games
and make them really
clean, well-defined puzzles
if you just ask, can
I win in one move?
Even games that involve cards
and randomness and weird stuff.
And one movie usually
doesn't involve those at all.
Anyway, here, we're getting rid
of the loopiness of the game
and not having to
worry about that.
So there's sort of two
parts to this proof,
the variable traversal
and the clause traversal.
But here, we have a kind
of very different way
of connecting things together.
We have a giant
matrix, if you will.
We're starting up
here and we have
a choice whether-- if we
want to set x1 to true,
we're just going to go to the
right by a sequence of jumps.
We jump here, then
here, then here.
Every time we stop,
we have no choice.
If we want to keep
going, our goal
is to get to somewhere, one
of the edges of the board,
I think the bottom edge.
Bottom edge is the one
that's hard to get to.
So every time we jump
to the right here,
we don't have a choice.
We have to keep
jumping to the right.
But over here, we have a choice.
We could go down and then jump
to the right and get over here
and that will do different
things in the middle.
In general, that is
our setting of x1.
Then, we're going to do
the same thing coming back
for x2 of two choices.
Then, the same thing
going back for x3
and then we get to this corner.
So that's forced other
than these two choices,
binary choices.
Now, we have our first clause.
Let's say x1 negated or
x2 negated or x3 negated.
We want one of those
things to be true.
And so the idea is we're
going to choose whichever
one has been set correctly and
then we will go up that channel
and get to the top.
Again, it's pretty
much symmetric.
So every time we jump
over a bunch of pieces,
whenever we stop, we
can't go left or right.
We have to keep going up.
So we have to make
it all the way.
In fact, each of these columns
will be completely filled
except for one
intersection, which is
the thing that makes it false.
So here, we want x2 to be false.
So if we happen to follow the
true path where x2 is true,
we won't make it because
this piece will already
have been removed when
we came through here.
And so if we try to take this
path, we'll get stuck here.
There won't be any
piece above us.
As long as that didn't happen,
as long as this row was not
chosen, then we can
take this column
and just make it all
the way up to the top.
So we're going to be able to
take one of these three paths
if and only if at least one
of these things is true.
That's the first clause.
Then, we do the same thing
for the second clause.
And if all of the
clauses are true,
we will be able to
get here and then
we can jump down and
get to the finish line
and win in one move, one move.
So mate in one is NP-complete.
I have one other example
of a mate in one result.
It's actually not a hardness
result, but it's kind of fun,
so I thought I would talk about
a non-hardness result for once,
which is checkers.
Checkers is another
game where in one move,
you can do a lot of jumps.
Especially if you
have a king, then you
can potentially win by killing
a lot of pieces all at once.
And this is considered
back in 1978.
This is the same
paper that proves
checkers is
EXPTIME-complete, which
we will get to at some point.
But for now, let's think
about the mate in one problem.
This turns out to be
easy, unlike phutball.
So checkers-- I assume
you've all played checkers.
You can only move diagonally
on the black squares.
So you can recast that
into an orthogonal problem
where the pieces can only
move orthogonally up or right
or vice versa,
except king pieces.
They can just move orthogonally.
And the interesting part
is when you can jump over
a piece of another color.
So if there was a black piece
here, this one can jump over.
And in general, if you have a
sequence of jumps you can make,
then you can do all
of them at once.
So the problem looks
something like this.
If you have a black piece and
let's say a black to move,
if there are a bunch of white
pieces, you can jump over them.
And the key thing
to notice-- again,
as soon as you jump over
a piece, it disappears.
So you can reuse
it in the same move
or I guess you can't
reuse it in general.
The key thing is that the jumps
preserve the parity, the even
or oddness of both
your x-coordinate
and your y-coordinate.
So you're moving around
on this reduced grid.
And so you can take
a picture like this
and turn it into a graph
where the potential positions
for you, which are drawn
with this kind of pattern,
same parity of rows and columns.
You could make those the
vertices of your graph.
And then, there's
an edge between them
if there's a white stone
in between that you
could jump over.
So then, given this
graph, the question
is, can you visit all of
the edges of the graph
with a single path?
And that is the Euler tour
problem or the Euler path
problem.
And it's easy to solve
that in polynomial time.
You look for
odd-degree vertices.
There should be at most two of
them and you better be at one
of them.
Or there's zero of them.
Then, you're happy.
So that's how to
solve mate in one
in checkers, in case you ever
get to those difficult checkers
endgames.
And now, you can decide how
to win or not in one move.
Two moves is left to you.
All right.
So next topic is
called cryptarithms.
This comes from the
recreational math world
and they're kind of fun.
You've probably seen this or
you may have seen this one
if you've seen any cryptarithm.
It's a classic.
It goes back to 1979 from
this book by Madachy.
And the idea is this is
an arithmetic formula,
SEND plus MORE equals MONEY.
And each of these letters
represents a digit zero
through nine.
And so these two M's represent
the same digit and so on.
Two n's represent
the same digits.
Those two O's represent
the same digit.
And furthermore, M is different
from O is differ from R.
So it's a bijection
between the letters that
appear in this puzzle and some
subset of zero through nine.
And it actually has
a unique solution.
This is it.
You could verify it,
but I'll leave it
as a puzzle so don't look at
that too long, in case you
want to solve it.
It is doable, but
the tricky part
are things like the carries
in the addition, which
make it not just a simple
linear system to solve.
And in fact, these puzzles,
generalized to an arbitrary
base, are NP-complete.
If you do it in base
10, then there's
only at most 10 factorial
possible solutions.
So that's constant and
that's considered fast.
And indeed, in
real computers, you
can solve 10
factorial reasonably.
So for generalized
base, here is a proof.
This is actually
David Eppstein, who
was a co-author in
the previous result.
This is his first theory
paper, "SIGACT News."
And it proved that it's
strongly NP-complete,
meaning even if the
base is polynomial,
the problem is NP-hard.
And it looks really messy, but
actually, it's fairly simple.
So let me start
with this gadget.
This is an easy one.
So there's no notion of
zero or one in this gadget,
but zero is just a letter
and one is just a letter.
But with this gadget
in place, 0 is
0 and 1 is 1, because 0's
the only possible digit when
you add it with yourself,
you get it again.
It is the identity
in additive ring.
So that forces 0 to be 0.
And then, here, we're
adding p with p.
P are just arbitrary things.
We sort of don't
care what they are.
We get something q.
And over here, we add
0 to 0 and we get 1.
That's only going to
be possible if there
was a carry in this column.
And carries can be only 1.
They can be 0 or 1.
So that forces--
we know it's not 0
because 1 is different from 0.
Therefore, 1 is 1.
The symbol 1 is the value
one, the number one.
All right.
So that gives us
some infrastructure.
And the zeroes are
really helpful,
because it lets us space
out gadgets and guarantee
that there's no
carry between them.
This is supposed to
be a variable gadget.
There's vi and there's vi bar.
So let's see what happens.
Let's do the vi part first.
So this formula says
that bi equals twice ai.
And there's guaranteed to
be no carry because of this.
Now, this is a little tricky.
We add yi to yi until we get zi.
So there may be a
carry or not here.
Then, we add bi to
bi and we get vi.
So vi is going to be 2
times bi plus either 0 or 1.
That's going to be
our binary choice.
We can set up the yi's
to either carry or not.
We'll call that C.
In this formulation,
C is the carry in
that operation.
And bi is 2 times ai.
So this is 4 times ai
plus C, which is 0 or 1.
And what we're going to
think about is modulo four.
This is congruent
to C. So we're going
to treat all of our variable
assignments modulo four
and they're always
going to be 0 or 1.
vi became this and the claim
is that this part makes
vi bar the opposite.
And you can work
through the arithmetic
as I did in the notes.
You end up vi bar has to be 4
times something, which is Ci.
So we don't care what that is.
We'll set it at the very
end, plus 3C plus 1.
C is 1, this is 4,
and this becomes 0.
If C is 0, this becomes 1 mod 4.
So in general, it's
1 minus C. It's
the opposite choice from what
vi was that becomes vi bar.
So that's cool.
We've got vi.
We've got vi bar.
We can duplicate our
variables for free,
because we can just
use that same letter
vi in many different
places and then
we just need a clause gadget.
And so the work is
similar kind of tricks.
We add fi to itself, we get gi.
We add gi to itself, we get hi.
So at this point, we have 4
times fi plus possibly one
carry.
This wi might carry or not.
So we get hi is 4
times fi plus 0 or 1.
Then, we add hi to
1 and we get ti,
plus there might be a
carry from this column.
So that's ti is going to be hi
plus 1 plus a potential carry.
hi is this thing, so we end up
with 4 times fi plus 1 plus 0
or 1 or 2, depending on how many
carries we've had total, which
is 4 times fi plus 1 or 2 or 3.
And modulo four, that
is one or two or three.
This is going to be the
number of true variables
in our clause, because in the
end, we just add vi plus vb.
We get this thing.
We add vc for our three
variables, a, b, and c.
We get ti.
And ti was that thing.
So if we just think about things
modulo four, that means va
plus vb plus vc should
be 1, 2, or 3 mod four.
Now, the reason we have this
junk-- and the junk's-- well,
OK.
There's the not
modulo four part,
the part when you divide by 4.
That's sort of tricky.
But at this point, at least,
you should be convinced
that if there's a solution
to this problem, then
there must be a solution to
the original 3SAT instance.
The reverse is less clear.
If you have a solution
to the 3SAT instance,
you have to be able to set
all these variables to make
everything work out.
That's a little more tedious.
For fun, and this
is an old proof 1987
and I was just looking
at it again today,
I think, or I think
it was yesterday.
I think I can simplify
it a little bit.
Instead of using
regular 3SAT where
you have all these choices, one,
two, or three things are true,
if you use exactly
one 3SAT, one in 3SAT,
it should be a lot easier.
So gadgets are smaller.
With one in 3SAT, we
don't need negation.
So I just need
the vi part, which
we did explicitly over here.
So that's kind of nifty.
And for exactly
one 3SAT, we don't
need to have all those carries.
We just need to build
four times something--
sorry, that should be fi here.
We add fi to itself.
We add gi to itself.
So here, we have 4 times fi.
And then, we add 1.
So this ti will be one mod four.
And then, we add
the variables up
and we should get
exactly one mod four.
Now, admittedly, I haven't
checked the second half
of the proof with
this construction,
but it seems
plausible this would
be a somewhat simpler proof.
So it shows you the power of all
the different versions of 3SAT
we saw last class.
Now, I can tell you a little
bit about the other direction.
I have some of the
details written down here.
So the other
direction is we need
to check if there's a satisfying
assignment to 3SAT or one
in 3SAT, that we can
actually construct
these numbers that the
base is only polynomial.
The trickiest part is to
get all of these numbers
to be distinct from each other.
AUDIENCE: What base do you do?
PROFESSOR: The base will
be something like n cubed,
it turns out.
And I'll tell you, one
trick is we have all these
ai's, bi's, and ci's.
We can guarantee they are all
different from each other,
that all the a's are different
from all the b's are different
from all the c's by saying all
a's-- let me get this right--
all a's will be 2,
34, 66, or 98 mod 128.
And in general, those
are particular numbers
set up to make this
construction work out.
I didn't check them
all but I believe them.
In general, we're going to
distinguish all the letters
by what they are mod 128.
So given a number
between zero and 127,
there's a unique letter of
the regular English letter
alphabet, the a's, the b's,
the y's, the z's, and so on
that it is assigned to.
And I'll tell you in particular,
the vi's and the vi bars
are going to be, I
think, 8 or 9 mod 128.
And the 8 is if
it's false and the 9
is if it's true, because
remember, modulo 4,
we want this to be zero
and we want this to be one.
So there's a bunch
of choices like that.
Some of them are unique.
We can always
guarantee-- I forget
which ones-- the ci's are
all something mod 128.
So the mod 128
will tell you sort
of what letter of
the English alphabet
it is and then it's
a matter of deciding
the high-order bits, your
number divided by 128
and take the floor.
What that is we set to
make everybody distinct.
And the heart of the
proof, I will say,
is to make sure that the
vi's are all different.
Or let's say that the
ti's are different.
So we have the variables here.
We're adding them up and
we get ti and we need all
of the ti's-- there's
one ti per clause.
We need them all
to be different,
which means no matter which
triple of vi's we get,
we should get a different
sum of the triples.
So this is a problem of
set vi and vi prime divided
by 128 so that vi plus vj
plus vk are all distinct.
And at this point,
Eppstein says,
oh, there's a result by Bose
and Chowla from 1959 the
says you can always choose these
guys-- if there's n of them
that you need to choose, then
n-cubed different integers
suffice to make this true.
That's if you know the
literature super well,
but there's an easy proof
that polynomials enough here.
And those of you
who are in 6.851
should be able to construct
one, because this is essentially
fusion trees.
But in general, imagine that
you've chosen by induction
I'll call them v less than i.
And let's ignore the primes.
Let's just say we've
constructed all the things up
to the vi minus 1.
And now, we want
to choose vi and it
needs to avoid certain values.
I think if it avoids vj plus
vk minus vl minus vm minus vp
for all j, k, l,
m, p less than i,
then no triple should
sum to any other triple,
because if we
add-- I think maybe
I have the signs slightly off.
So I wanted to do this.
Yeah, so this is one more plus.
So suppose I had an
equation like this.
I claim that's bad because
if I move these guys over
to the left-hand side, that's
a triple of v's that sums
to another triple of v's.
So as long as I choose
my new value v-- sorry,
this should vi.
That's the one I'm choosing.
As long as I choose vi to be
different from all such sums
and they're only less than
n to the fifth such sums,
because there are only n
of these different things,
then I'm OK.
And so by the
pigeonhole principle,
as long as I have
a range that is
at least n to the
fifth in size, then
I can always choose vi to
avoid all those conflicts.
So that's a really easy proof
that n to the fifth is enough.
In fact, n cubed is enough,
but this is a hardness proof.
All we need is strong hardness.
We just need n cubed.
That's just fine
or n to the fifth.
Any polynomial would be OK.
So that's a sketch of
the reverse direction
for this proof.
There are some more
details to make sure
everything adds up right
mod 128 and that you
can make all the ai's
different and so on,
but the hard part is the
vi's, which seems believable.
Questions about cryptarithms?
Cool.
Next is an origami proof.
So here's the
motivating problem.
I give you some
crease pattern, which
is just a graph drawn in
a plane, no crossings,
and all the edges are
straight segments.
And you want to fold
it into a flat origami
or a flat folded state would
be the more technical term.
So this is an example of what's
called an origami tessellation.
But in general, what
you're allowed to do,
the red lines here
mean that you fold
as a mountain by 180
degrees and the blue lines
mean you fold a
valley 180 degrees.
So they're specifying
the relative orientation.
But in flat-folding,
you're only allowed
to go plus or minus 180.
And then, it has to exist.
Now, the rules for
paper are twofold.
One is that it doesn't stretch.
It's an isometric mapping
of the piece of paper.
Each of these little
polygons is just rotated,
translated, reflected
possibly over here.
They fit together, so
you don't tear the paper.
They fit together
at all the creases
and there are no
crossings, because paper
can't intersect itself.
So the geometry is basically
determined if you say,
OK, I'm going to view
this panel as being fixed.
It doesn't move.
Then, this one is just
going to be a reflection
through this line flipped over.
And in general, all of
these other polygons
just have to be reflections,
because every time you
fold on a line-- and
the rules of the game
here is you have to fold
everywhere there's a crease.
You can figure out this polygon
will end up here relative
to some original polygon.
So you can figure out
pretty much what this
looks like as an x-ray diagram.
And the hard part becomes
how are layers stacked.
Is this one on top
of this one or is
this one on top of that one?
That's why the problem
is NP-complete is
that last step, deciding which
layers are on top of the other.
In general, whenever two layers
of paper partially overlap,
you have to decide which
is on top of the other.
And then, there's some
obvious constraints
like-- let me get my hands
oriented-- this is OK
but this is not OK.
If there's one
crease of paper here
and another crease
of paper here,
then these locally intersect.
So this is OK.
This is OK.
This is not OK.
That's the rules.
We don't need to know
those rules super precisely
to understand this
proof fairly intuitively
because everything's going
to be small and quite local.
The basic idea is the following.
You take a piece of
paper and you fold it
along two parallel lines.
So fold along this line
and then along this line.
And this is called a pleat and
there are two ways to do it.
You could do one
mountain, one valley,
or you could do the other one
mountain and the other one
valley.
You can't make them both
mountains because then, you'd
locally intersect yourself.
So it could be this
way or it could
be the other way I just had it.
It's a little tedious.
And so you have to
make that choice.
Which one is a mountain?
Which one is a valley?
That's going to be
our true signal.
We're going to consider one
option true, the other option
false.
And as a point of
notation, we're
going to have an arrow
in every one of these--
we call them wire gadgets.
In general, wires are how
we have truth settings.
And so relative to the
orientation of this arrow,
if it's valley on
the left-- blue
is valley because I guess
rivers are in valleys--
then we'll consider it true.
If there's blue on the right,
we'll consider it false.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Just a
question about the SAT.
Once you draw all the
red and blue lines,
there's just one unique answer?
PROFESSOR: No, the answer's
not necessarily unique,
but there will be a
unique yes or no answer.
Either it will be
flat-foldable or not,
but there actually may
be many flat foldings
consistent with a given
mountain-valley assignment
in general.
So we're not worrying
about that too much here.
We're just worrying about
whether it is feasible,
whether there's some ordering
that makes things work out.
So the idea is this
could be your variable.
Some reductions have
variable gadgets.
Some don't.
This one is just
going to have a wire.
The idea is if you
say, well, there's
a pleat over here
in the paper, then
it could be pleated
one way or the other.
And that serves as
a variable, as you
make one choice or the other.
What we'd like is to take that
truth value and duplicate it,
make many copies.
But that's not the next gadget.
The next gadget is a not
all equal clause gadget.
So this is going
to be a reduction
from not all equal 3SAT.
And I have the gadget
pre-folded here.
So this is what in origami world
is called a triangular twist.
It's a slightly weird
triangular twist,
in that this is 35
degrees instead of 30
being the usual one.
And so it's just a
little bit larger
and that causes a problem.
So this is an example of a valid
flat-folding of that gadget.
And if you look at the three
pleats that are coming in,
notice the arrows
are all pointing in.
So it's sort of symmetric.
It's going to be one
of the valid ones.
So I guess it's actually
written on the diagram here.
This one is considered
true because there's
a valley on your right,
this one is considered false
because there's a
valley on your-- oh
I'm so confused-- on
your right, and this one
is considered true
because there's
a valley on your left-- oh,
sorry, false because there's
a valley on your right.
If you're walking
down the arrow,
then the right-hand
side has a valley.
And so this happens to
fold because they're not
all the same.
If you tried to make
them all the same, which
should be like
reversing the true,
it's going to look something
like this, which is actually
easier to see back here.
So now, they're all trying
to fold the same way.
But the problem is on this side.
These guys will all come
and intersect in the center.
And I think we
have a diagram Here
And in x-ray, this
is what must happen.
And there's this little area of
intersection where you cannot
resolve which of these three
things are on top of each other
because this one wants be on
top of this one who wants to be
on top of this one who wants
to be on top of this one.
So there's a cycle
of constraints.
No one can be on top of each
other in this little region.
Then, in the regular
triangle twist,
this is a point and
everything's fine.
But the way these
angles are set up,
there's this area of overlap.
And in that one
situation, you're
toast So if they're all
true-- but of course,
everything symmetric.
If you flip it over, then it's
the same if they're all false.
So you forbid all true.
You forbid all false.
Everything else will work
so this is not all equal.
This will be
flat-foldable locally
if and only if those variable
assignments are not all equal.
Now, we need a couple more
gadgets for this to work.
One is the ability
to duplicate a signal
and the other is a crossover.
So here, this is a proof by
Burn and Hayes, by the way.
This is, I think, the
first or second paper
in computational origami.
So it got things off
to an exciting start.
This is a
splitter/negation gadget.
This is what it folds like.
It looks a little bit weird
because my paper's a little bit
small, but the point
is there's essentially
only one way to fold this.
And if you take 6,849, you'll
know this little local analysis
that forces different mountains
and valleys to be the same.
For example, these
two have to be
opposite, which forces
if this is a true,
this one must be a false.
So that's your negation.
And also from a local
analysis of this vertex,
if this one is true,
this one must be true.
And it works and it also
works in the inverse setup.
That's always going to be true.
A natural reason for us to
be using not all equal 3SAT
here is there's
really no preference
between true and false.
They're not really
a logical notion.
It's more like red and blue,
literally red and blue.
So not all equal is the one
that's nice and symmetric.
It has no preference
between red and blue.
And so we're seeing that here.
Because everything's
invertible, we
want that symmetry
between red and blue.
So that would be
one reason to guest
not all equal 3SAT is
a good choice here,
at least for that wire.
So cool, if we have a
signal, we can make a copy.
We also get two copies.
One of them happens
to be negated
with this particular choice
of arrow orientation.
If we oriented the
arrow the other way,
you could call
that a copy, but we
don't want to take a
wire that's pointing
backwards because we need to
attach this to something else.
These all have very
particular angles,
but it turns out
that will be OK.
One more gadget is
a crossover gadget.
This is very simple.
It is just one-- this is
not the pre-folded one-- you
do one pleat and then
you do the other pleat.
And you can see from
the crease pattern,
you have to do this pleat
and then do this pleat.
But it's completely independent.
I could do each
pleat either way.
It doesn't affect the other one.
So that's crossover, done, easy.
This works with pretty
much any angles.
And then, it's just a matter
of checking that you can
fit all the gadgets together.
This is something
we did in our book
to get a picture of
how everything works.
But in general, the idea is
on the left side of the page,
we have all of our variables.
Those are just wires so they
can go one way or the other.
So the idea is here is x2.
I just want to bend it so
it's pointing downwards
so I'm going to use the
splitter/negation gadget.
So we get this copy
of x2 just going off.
It's going to go up to the
top of the page, no big deal.
Just throw it away.
Then, we're going
to go over here.
Something happens to cross
us, but we don't care.
Now, what I would
like to do-- looks
like this clause involves x2.
So I'm going to do this funny
kind of turnaround thingy
which will end up making a
copy of this variable pointing
straight up and also will make
a copy of the variable pointing
in this direction.
And so in general, I'm
going to keep doing that.
And whenever I need
a copy, I'll just
use an appropriate parity of
turns to get a positive copy.
So this is negated and then
this is a copy of the negation
and then we flip it
one, two, three times.
So in the end, it
should be positive.
So this is the
tricky part to check.
Here, we have a not all
equal 3SAT clause where
three things come together.
And that's going to be
foldable if and only
if the three variables
that we're combining
have a reasonable assignment.
And then, we just have
to copy all these things
and get them to meet all at
those nexuses at the top.
So definitely tricky
to make sure this works
to guarantee all
the coordinates can
be encoded with a
polynomial number of bits.
And therefore, this is a
strongly NP-hard proof.
But I'm going to wave my
hands of those details.
Questions?
If it's any consolation,
the original proof
also waves its hand
at these details.
AUDIENCE: If you have a
fold pattern like this,
can you tell what order you
would need to do the folds in?
PROFESSOR: There's no such thing
as order of the folds here.
All of the folds would be folded
simultaneously, more or less.
AUDIENCE: Instantaneously.
PROFESSOR: Instantaneously,
to make it even more precise.
So here, it was
really a question
of whether there is
a flat-folded state.
We're not worried about
the motion to get there.
That's another topic
which you should take 8.49
if you're curious about.
But these kinds of patterns,
you can't do one thing
because there's no pleat
that goes all the way.
And that's life, unlike
the folding problem
we saw two classes ago, the map
folding where we were doing one
and then the other.
In the notion of simple
folds, there's an ordering,
but in general origami,
there is no ordering.
Cool.
Good, that is origami stuff.
The next topic is a more graph
theoretic basic question,
but it will also
relate to a puzzle.
And this is the idea of
vertex disjoint paths.
This is in Jason
Lynch's early work,
before he was born, no relation.
1975, so early days of
NP-completeness-- this problem,
vertex disjoint paths in a
graph is proved NP-complete.
So the problem is, I give you
a bunch of terminal pairs, v1,
v1 prime, v2, v2 prime,
and so on, c1, c1 prime,
a bunch of pairs of vertices.
And I want to connect
the pairs by paths.
So I want to find a path
from v1 to v1 prime and so
on so that those paths
are all vertex disjoint.
Here's the hardness proof.
Super simple-- this is one of
the easiest 3SAT reductions.
This is not the
end of their paper.
They do more interesting
things, which I will get to,
but first, let's
understand this one.
So this is a graph and I've
drawn it in a funny way.
These are vertices.
These are not vertices.
Those are just in the
plane, they happen to cross,
but there's no vertex there.
So it's just a straight
path all the way through.
Kind of similar to what we
did with phutball-- the idea
is that from v1 to v1
prime, there are two paths,
at least if you stay here.
You could try to go into a
clause path and wreak havoc,
but I think you will
be doomed, I hope.
So the idea is v1, maybe
you choose the blue path.
That will prevent c3 from
using that path because there's
an intersection here.
It won't prevent anybody
else because there's
no other vertices here.
So I use the blue path,
c3 cannot use that path.
If I use the red path,
c1 can't use this
one. c2 can't use this one.
So again, we are
blocking the thing
that it would be setting false.
So that means, let's say red--
I forget in this picture-- let's
say red is true.
Then, c1 has v1 bar in it.
c1 is happy if you
choose the blue path
but it's not happy if
you choose the red path.
Now, c1 to c1 prime
only has to be happy
if one of these three things
are happy and that's 3SAT.
At least one of the things
should be set correctly.
Then, there is a path
from c1 to c1 prime.
Otherwise, there'll be
vertex intersections.
You won't have vertex
disjoint paths.
So in a graph, done.
Now, let's make it a planar
graph, where things get fun.
So this is the original gadget.
I've stared at it
for many hours,
but it's actually
pretty simple after you
stare at it for enough hours.
Let me try to
convince you of that.
So I'm going to follow the
same kind of outline here,
but we have to get rid of these.
These are fine.
Those are intersections.
But these crossovers, we need
to build a crossover gadget.
So the idea is
instead of v1 to v1
prime being a single path--
that's going to be a problem.
Instead of that, I'm going
to have it be several paths
and they're going to
be nested brackets.
Chalk-- this is the kind
of thing we're imagining.
We have some vertex pairs
which can connect like this.
And there are two ways
to connect them in what
will end up being the diagram.
We could connect them like this.
Notice I'm still connecting the
same pairs if I do it right.
And the whites do not
intersect each other.
They're vertex disjoint.
The reds do not
intersect each other.
They're vertex disjoint.
But if you tried to
switch from white to red,
you'd get intersections.
There's exactly
two settings here.
So this is a wire.
Once I choose over
here white or red,
all the others are
forced to alternate.
Oh, sorry.
Once I choose up
or down, the rest
are forced to
alternate up or down.
If I choose white here,
they're all white.
If I choose red,
they're all red.
This is independent
for each variable,
so independent for each wire.
So that's what's going on
here and if you look closely
at the bold lines, you've got
a bracket here from v1 to x1.
Then, you've got a bracket
here from x2 to x3, then
a bracket here from x4.
But in general, there would be
lots of those brackets going
all the way down the picture.
And the cool thing about
this is you get the ability
to crossover,
because now if I just
restrict this picture--
it's hard to see-- if I just
restrict to the white part,
you can go from top to bottom.
You just need an
appropriate kind of zigzag.
That will let you go from
up here to down there
without intersections
and that's what's
happening with this line.
It's going over, around
the brackets, and down.
And so the c1 to c1 prime
can remain a single path.
It can always get through.
If you have this
gadget, then you
can have an intersection
with no trouble.
But v1 is still
communicating information
down the line of one setting
or the other, 0 or 1.
There's some details to check
there, but that's the idea.
And that's the end
of the Lynch paper.
Now, we were looking at
this earlier this year
and we can prove an even
stronger result, which
is what you might call
planar vertex disjoint
paths in a rectangle.
So the idea is you
have a rectangle
of one-by-one squares.
Each one-by-one square could be
a terminal and a terminal pair
or it could just
be a blank space
so you can route paths through.
And my goal is to find vertex
disjoint paths connecting
all the terminal pairs.
But furthermore, I want
every square of the grid
to be occupied by a path.
So it's not quite
Hamiltonian path.
It's like you have a bunch
of paths that collectively
fill the entire grid.
Why?
It's motivated by a puzzle,
but it's natural enough.
This is a more
specialized version.
So this is also
NP-hard and we're
going to mimic the same proof.
And this, for
example, is a gadget
to do, say, this little picture
where you have two choices.
So maybe the v1 dot
is actually here
and the idea is you could
either follow this path
or you can follow this path.
And what's also drawn here are
lots of other terminal pairs.
These are what you might
call adjacent terminal pairs,
what you might also
call obstacles.
Because the paths have
to be vertex disjoint,
no path can go
through a terminal.
Any of these dots
serve as obstacles
so we effectively simulate this
blank space that you're not
allowed to touch.
Now, the fun part is
maybe those terminal
pairs are connected by
the single edge that
joins them and doesn't
get in the way.
But there are
other possibilities
drawn with these blue lines.
So instead of going
here, I could do this.
Instead of going here, I
could do this and this.
And then, if you
look at this picture,
every pixel has a path
through it in this case.
And then, here's
the other case again
and now I'll fill these
two pixels with this pair.
And now, every pixel
has a path through it.
That's my goal is to
make sure every pixel has
a path through it.
So we're just trying
to preserve all
of the solutions
we have here but
with the additional
constraint that all
of the-- because we already
know this is simulating 3SAT.
We already know it's hard.
We just now want to have
this extra constraint
that every pixel has
a path through it
and that we live in a rectangle.
So this looks good.
As you might imagine, there's
a little bit of finesse
to make these gadgets work.
You notice some of these guys
are oriented horizontally.
Some of them are
oriented vertically.
That's to make it
work, but this is easy.
What you're about
to see is less easy.
So let's do the crossover
gadget, because that's
the heart of everything.
And when we were
starting on this--
I think this was in
May-- I was very happy
when I could finally
draw this picture.
Sorry, this is actually
the final gadget
which works but you can see
the same kind of picture.
I've got a bracket here that
corresponds to this bracket
here and there's
another bracket here.
I've just rounded it
to integer coordinates
and made sure that everything
else can be filled in.
Easy, right?
In the sake of education, let
me show you all the things that
went wrong in this proof.
Because it was only
a few months ago,
I mostly remember
everything that went wrong,
which was a lot.
So this was an early
version of the gadget,
not actually the first one
but it serves its purpose.
So here, we have
the two settings.
It's corresponding to
these two settings, the up
and the down setting, the
true and the false setting.
We've got this path coming
through in both cases.
It takes a slightly
different path over here.
The brackets are flipped.
So the first thing
I want to point out
are these circled nodes.
The obvious way to
draw this picture
is with all of the
terminals in the center row.
That would be reasonable.
They're not drawn that way here
because imagine at this point,
we're down here and we have
this big path over here.
Then, there'll be
three pixels here which
somehow have to be filled.
And that is trouble
because three is odd.
So this is what you
might call issue one.
Wherever you have
empty space, any group
should have even area because
if you look at two guys that
are adjacent and you replace
them with some other path,
together, that forms a polygon.
And in the square grid
every polygon has even area.
So you will never fill
exactly three spaces.
So the major revolution which
I spent many hours figuring out
is if I just move these
points up one spot,
everything just works.
I was so happy.
So I figured, OK, proof's done.
I drew these two figures
and forgot about it.
Then, a couple months later,
we want to write the paper
and then we get to issue two.
So issue two is
well, this is great.
This works fine if the
clause path is present.
If the clause chooses
this vertical path,
this will fill everything.
This will fill everything.
But what if the
clause path is absent?
Clause has three choices.
It may not choose
this vertical path.
So then, somehow, this stuff
has to be covered using
all the extra filler stuff.
And here, I couldn't
quite figure out
how to fill these things.
Well, maybe I should add a
couple more rows in the middle.
That didn't seem to help.
I thought this one was OK.
It looks fine until I
notice that well, either I
connect these two dots
by a length two path
or I connect it by this path.
But in that case, this
pixel is uncovered by paths.
And this is bad, because there's
exactly one such pixel, which
means I have another
parity problem again.
So I think what we
ended up doing--
and when you're really doing
it, you don't immediately
realize it's a parity problem.
I tried trying to fix
this many, many times
and every single time, I
had one pixel uncovered.
Oh, bet there's a theorem here.
And then, I proved, oh, yeah,
it's got to change parity.
So what we ended up doing
was adding a row down here.
Make this path slightly longer.
That adds exactly
one uncovered pixel
so it should fix
the parity problem.
Many hours later, we
came up with this.
So this is good.
Every pixel is covered
in all four cases.
The bottom row is that
the clause path is in
and the top row is the
clause path is out.
And as you can see, lots
of careful orientations
of these little terminal pairs
to make sure in all cases,
you can cover everything.
This was frustrating
because you'd fix one
and then you switch
to the other layer
and say, oh, I broke
this other one.
I rotated these guys and now,
it's not possible to do this,
so you better-- and
it would be like,
you'd rotate this and then
rotate that and rotate this.
And luckily, no bad
cycles happened.
You could always resolve it.
And so finally, we
got this picture,
except for issue three, which
is another parity problem.
I was blown away.
It was like every day, there
was another parity problem.
Of course, the deadline
is tomorrow at this point.
Luckily, I started
three days ahead
so there were
exactly three issues.
So remember this gadget,
which was the choice.
I didn't say this is
a variable choice.
You have two choices.
If you want a clause choice,
you connect two of these gadgets
together and then you
have three different paths
you might follow.
If you stare at this
enough-- and I just
wanted to make sure, OK,
can I plug these together?
I thought, OK, I'll just copy
and paste and lay things out
and I had a parity problem.
I was like, oh, man,
what's going on?
Well, if you look here,
this is at one column
and this is a column
four positions over.
So in particular,
the two choices
here have the same parity.
I think it's mod 2 not mod
4 but I could double-check.
And you just cannot build this
if you want these things to be
an odd distance
apart because parity.
So then, you look at
this gadget and you
realize it has an odd
number of columns.
We've made it an
even number of rows
when we added that
last row but now
it has an odd number of
columns, which is kind of weird
but that's life.
So we need to make it even.
And so I think if
you focus right here,
we add another column.
It's now right here so
where there used to be two,
now there are three.
We have this little trick
to fill things in and not
too much changed.
I think I also
cleaned up the gadget
or removed a couple extra
columns on the right,
but the key thing was
to add a new column that
fixed the parity.
Now, the number
of columns is even
and now, I have to prove this.
But it's pretty easy to check.
You can combine these gadgets
together and they match up.
And then, if you
have blank space,
it's also even by even and so
it always has a perfect matching
and so you can fill in any
blank space with extra pairs.
Those are the gadgets
except there's one more
issue I haven't mentioned.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, there's
a parity problem
with your parity problems.
There's only an
odd number of them.
PROFESSOR: Only an odd
number of parity problems--
luckily, the next problem
is not a parity problem
or unluckily-- I don't know.
And this wasn't
really a problem.
I knew it was going to happen.
I just had to draw the figure
but it's good for an exercise.
Think about what could
possibly be missing.
We spent all this time
doing crossover gadgets
but there's also the case
where the wires cross
and we actually want
the vertical wire
to block the horizontal
wire in a particular choice.
This is actually
really easy to do.
So here's the gadget
I was just showing you
without all the stuff filled in.
Those are just the
terminal pairs.
And this guy goes to the left.
This guy goes to here.
This guy goes to the right.
If you just add in an extra
pair here or an extra pair here,
you will block blue or
red, correspondingly.
So if we go to the
previous slide here,
blue goes through this
position but red does not.
And down here, blue does
not go through this position
but red does.
And so if you add in
this extra little pair,
you will force red or
blue at that intersection.
And that was the little
squares in the overall diagram.
So if you choose
this vertical path,
you force the horizontal
path to be the other thing.
That's the proof.
I hope there are no more
issues but it was exciting.
So just to give you a
flavor for parity issues,
there are all over the
place, especially when you're
on a grid.
Be careful of them.
That's the life lesson.
I'll tell you a little bit
about where this kind of problem
comes from.
The earliest reference we know
is by Sam Loyd, a famous puzzle
designer.
In 1897, he posed this puzzle,
an incredibly complicated
puzzle, lots of stuff in it.
And then, I think
the next issue,
he published the
solution, which is this.
Hopefully, I
remember the problem.
So you have these
houses and you'll notice
each house faces an exit.
And what you'd like
is for each house
to be connected by a
pathway to the exit.
But if you just did that, they
would intersect each other.
So you want vertex
disjoint paths
in the grid from the houses
to the exit that they face.
So that is a terminal pair
vertex disjoint path problem.
Now, he didn't specify
that those paths should
fill the entire grid
but they almost do.
Other than this
little corner, they
do and a few little
corners at the extremes.
And you can fix it.
Instead of going
like this, you can
go zig, zig, zig, zig, and
zig, zig, zig, zig, zig
and make it into a solution
to the problem I just said.
So that's 1897.
In modern terms, this is known
as the Numberlink puzzle.
Nikoli is a famous
Japanese puzzle publisher.
These are two Nikoli books
that we got in our last trip
to Japan a couple months ago.
These are both for
the Numberlink puzzle.
So you turn to an arbitrary
page and you have some picture
like this, which
here's an example.
You have pairs.
You have a bunch of
numbers and blank spaces.
The idea is that there's
exactly two of each number.
Those are your terminal pairs.
You want to find vertex
disjoint paths that connect them
and in the back,
there's solutions
if you can't solve one.
They have easy ones,
medium ones, hard ones.
So how hard is it?
NP-hard because this is exactly
the problem we were just
solving, if you want
to find vertex disjoint
paths in the grid.
There is this issue
of whether you
are specified as one
of the constraints
that you must
visit every square.
But do a quick visual scan
here-- in every solution
that I see, every square
happens to be filled.
Now, that might be the
way that they designed
the puzzles, the only way to
solve them is for every square
to be filled or it might
be that's a constraint
to the puzzle.
And different write-ups
suggest different ways.
But what we proved is,
both ways, it's hard.
Whether you give that as a
specification or you make
it possible to do, it is
NP-hard because we started
from a reduction that didn't
have to fill every pixel
and we turned it
into one that could
fill every pixel if you wanted.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There's a sense
in which these puzzles are
sparser, in terms of
the number of vertices
than your reduction.
Is it possible that you
could define it in such a way
that these are unsolvable?
PROFESSOR: It's an
interesting question.
So our reduction has most of
the cells filled with numbers.
These you could say, if you
have an n by n grid, maybe
these only have order
n numbers, whereas we
have order n squared numbers.
That would be interesting.
I don't know the complexity.
The one thing that's known
is for one terminal pair,
it's polynomial time.
I think even two terminal
pairs is an open problem.
So you need to solve that
before you could solve
n terminal pairs for an n by n.
So I don't know how many people
worked on two terminal pairs.
I've thought about
it a little bit.
It seems very difficult.
Anyway, a little
more to this story.
In fact, we first
encountered Numberlink
in the form of an Android
game called Flow Free, which
some of you may have played.
It became popular for
a few months there
but it is exactly Numberlink
as I have defined it.
And once you know
that, then there's
also Number Link and a
zillion other clones.
And I don't think Nikoli
publishes any of these.
But it's all from
1897, so unclear
what the copyright is here.
But in particular,
Number Link I like.
It has the nicest GUI.
But in the beginning
tutorial, it
says, well, there's actually
two modes you can play.
There's zigzag mode, where
you can draw paths however
you want.
That's what I've been
talking about because
graphed theoretically,
that's the natural thing.
Then, there's this other
modes called classic mode
where if you draw
a complicated path,
it gets-- "autoshrinked"
is the general term.
Now, again, it's hard to
have an authority here
in what are the
rules of Number Link?
But one definition
is you consider
all possible paths
between these pairs that
have the same topology.
You can try to go this way or
you could try to go this way.
Here, you have these two
guys on your right-hand side.
Here, you have them
on the left-hand side.
In general, that's called a
homotopy type of that path.
Consider all paths with
the same homotopy type.
Your path should be shortest
among all such paths.
That is one notion
of autoshrinked.
I don't know if that's the
official one, but it is a--
AUDIENCE: That has to do
with the order in which you
set the things.
PROFESSOR: This description
suggests a particular order.
So you'd also maybe
need a proper ordering.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the
1 to the 1 here,
there's multiple ways--
well, the other way,
there's multiple ways to get
through that square grid,
I think.
You can go down and all the
way around or you could go--
PROFESSOR: Right.
These would both
be the same length.
And I think those are
both considered valid,
although you'd have to
play in this particular--
AUDIENCE: So it wouldn't
change either of those.It
would take the one you chose.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you still have
some flexibility.
There are multiple shortest
paths in this world,
because we're Manhattan metric.
So this raises the issue
of classic Number Link.
And most of the puzzles--
I think all the puzzles-- I
haven't checked every
single one-- actually
follow these rules.
But again, I'm not clear
what the rules actually
are, whether they
require this or this.
But luckily, there's another
paper the covers that case.
It's in Japanese but it
considers the classic mode,
where you have to do some kind
of locally shortest paths.
And the gadgets critically
exploit that feature.
It's a reduction
from planar 3SAT.
We might look at it when
we get to planar 3SAT,
which is the next class or two.
Or not-- there's a ton
of planar 3SAT proofs.
But anyway, that's
been covered already.
The actual order of events
is we proved our result
and then we're like, uh
oh, this is Numberlink.
Uh oh, Numberlink is
NP-complete and that
was known a few years ago.
Oh, good thing it's a
different game that we studied.
So there are two versions
of Numberlink now.
They're both hard.
So that's the good news
and that's all for today.
This is the Super Mario
Brothers edition of 6.890.